yves salara was inspired by art the
french fashion designers creations often
mirrored his favorite artworks or echoed
their essence through colour or pattern
painters including brock and picasso
infused
creative vision he never copied but
reinvented in his unique style the
pompidou center is one of six top
museums in paris showcasing the
influence of art on the designer he was
picking up different kind of
inspirations from the contemporary
artists like warhol or wesselmann or
royensenstein but also modern artists
matisse or even pharmacology we could
say he had like a museum without walls
in his mind this pompidou curator says
the exhibition illustrates how fashion
can be an art form
it's an honor for us to have yves saint
laurent's creations alongside our
permanent collection in the pompidou and
i think it's the first time the show has
made a link between the designer's work
and contemporary art eve salary's love
affair with art is nowhere more evident
than in his mondrian inspired dresses a
tribute to the dutch artist daring
playful and modern they caused a
sensation when revealed in 1965.
as well as the pompidou center paris's
modern art museum the orsay picasso and
ysl museums are all part of the
exhibition but the most prestigious is
the louvre where some of sauron's most
luxurious and intricate designs reveal
his passion for ornamental art and all
things gold
i think the absolute dream for him would
have been to be exhibited for his
designs to interact with his sources of
inspiration
it's a dream he never imagined would
actually happen
[Music]
revolutionized women's fashion he gave
women beauty but also power he
challenged ideals and upset stereotypes
sixty years after his first fashion show
and more than a decade after his death
dozens of salahurang garments and 300
designs will be on show an enticing
tribute to one of the world's most
revered designers natasha butler al
jazeera paris